et pour en parler nous sommes avec
younes d'elfes et la consultant en
relations internationales bonsoir younès
belle fait là bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous sur rtl france cette conférence de
munich les français n'y avait pas
participé depuis plus de dix ans
emmanuel macron a choisi d'y aller
pourquoi je crois qu'il a acquis ad des
nouvelles choses en fait tu as à dire
par rapport à tout ce qui s'était passé
récemment avec rendre la défense
européenne également la défense
européenne mais plutôt la division avec
les années les américains on est face à
un effondrement du projet de l'otan une
nouvelle position européenne les
européens maintenant on cherche à avoir
leur propre agenda politique avec un
projet de défense
bien sûr le diable est dans le détail
parce qu'il faut voir un petit peu
comment on peut financer ce genre de
projet parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'initiatives mais il faut pas compter
sur certains pays européens la france
allait amener une guerre au sahel tout
seul sans avoir aucun aide au prix de la
ville et ses places d'ailleurs de
l'ambition d' emmanuel macron de monter
les désertions européenne et donc ce qui
fait que là il faut être très réaliste
par rapport à ce genre de projet est de
mettre sur la table des priorités moi je
trouve que la priorité c'est d'abord ce
qui se passe dans la méditerranée la
géopolitique du gaz principalement la
libye la lutte contre le terrorisme
ça ce sont des sujets qui sont
extrêmement série également importer la
crise en syrie ce qui est intéressant
c'est que maintenant on est face à une
nouvelle phase dans l'ordre mondial
donc si fait il ya des pays qui
cherchent maintenant à voir des projets
ambitieux soit pour redorer le blason
année à une histoire comme le cas de la
russie ou même la turquie où on peut
arriver c'est de la chine là dessus ou
bien d'autres pays comme le projet
américain qui vise en fin de compte
consolider les acquis des américains et
leur leadership sur sur sur le monde et
donc ce qui fait que il ya beaucoup
d'enjeux là dessus et je crois que au
niveau européen dès récemment avec le
break site
on a besoin de revoir tout le modèle
européen avec une priorité essentielle
qui est la question de la défense se
formait de munich qui permet des
discussions peut-être moins formelle que
lors d'un g7 par exemple
intéressant pour la france notamment
l'appel qu'il a lancé à l'allemagne pour
relancer la défense européenne à se
montrer à relancer l' aventure
européenne vous pensé que c'était un
appel qui est vain c'est un appel qui
est très nécessaire mais il faut prendre
en considération que les allemands ils
vont avoir en fin de compte une nouvelle
élection on sait pas le mouvement qui va
gagner en quelque sorte les élections et
si l'allemagne va continuer dans notre
dans notre union européenne les
caractéristiques de ce projet je crois
qu'il ment campus plus de simplification
plus d'explications par rapport à ce
qu'on peut mettre en exergue
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que par
rapport aux chiffres qui ont été
présentés hier notamment le rapport de
l'institut international des études
stratégiques aux états unis c'est cette
augmentation dont les budgets d'armement
qui est très intéressante et sa mère en
fin de compte une inquiétude avoir 4 %
d'augmentation dans les budgets
d'armement comme communes moyennes
les américains qui ont investi 700
milliards de dollars juste dans la
technologie militaire les chinois qui
ont augmenté leur budget de 25 % dans
les cinq dernières dernières années sont
autant de questions et de points qui
méritent d'être d'être discutée et qu'il
faut les prendre en considération pour
avoir un projet clair et une vision
sincères devant les citoyens européens
est bien évidemment de prendre en
considération tous les changements qui
se passe dans la carte mondiale
il ya une donnée aussi intéressante
c'est que les états unis ne veulent plus
être le gendarme du monde
en tout cas c'est une volonté affichée
dans le discours du coup
est ce que munich est une opportunité
intéressante pour relancer cette défense
je crois que c'est un c'est un forum
c'est comme si en fin de compte on
parlait de davos dans l'économie donc à
munich la sécurité donc effectivement il
faut avoir maintenant une conscience
très intéressante par rapport à ce
projet de train qui peut être à le
projet qui va continuer au moins pour
les cinq prochaines les cinq prochaines
années le fait de se retirer du sahel
par exemple les insectes une stratégie
bon il ya beaucoup de questions là
dessus sur la question d'une stratégie
de repli au niveau des seuils
mais le sahel ou bien le la libye c'est
des questions qui sont extrêmement
stratégique pour la france et des zones
d'influencé pour la france
on ne peut pas accepter avoir des bases
militaires turcs en libye ou bien avoir
une nouvelle organisation d'al qaeda
dans les frontières devant les portes de
l'europe ce qui va représenter un
extrême danger pour l'union européenne
mais je crois qu'il faut avoir un
nouveau projet pour la méditerranée
impliquer d'autres pays soient delà de
la zone francophone ou bien de l'autre
rive de la méditerranée ça veut dire les
pays les pays du sud dans ce genre de
projet soit par le financement par
l'équipement par la question de la
formation le transfert de l'expertisé
dans la matière dans la matière de la
défense et avoir une volonté politique
sincère de dire que le projet européen
c'est le seul projet maintenant c'est la
seule issue face aux européens
pour continuer dans cette démarche s aux
amériques face aux américains est
également face aux russes parce que l'on
a on a vu qu'il ya une déclaration de
monsieur mac rang qui était très très
très fort on comprend pas bien pourquoi
pourquoi emmanuel macron a lancé cette
phrase contre l'ingérence russe il va
parler de défense à proprement parler
mais aussi d' ingérence sur les réseaux
sociaux ce qui arrive en pleine affaire
griveaux qui a priori rien à voir avec
ce qui se passe on l'a fait à fargues et
vous l a rien à voir avec avec ce qui se
passe au niveau de munich on parle de
relations internationales mais ce qui
est intéressant par rapport à ce qui
était déçu sur la russie de poutine
c'est que il ya un différend français
sur la question de la syrie il ya même
un conflit avec avec la russie là dessus
sur également l'affluence de la russie
ce serait un pays africains notamment
les pays de la corne d'afrique la russie
elle a même créé des bases militaires
dans sept à dans cette région mais je
crois qu aussi le président macron veut
vraiment redresser les relations avec
avec poutine on sait parfaitement qu'il
y avait trois roues amélioré en tout cas
depuis depuis 2010 est notamment la ma
fameuse rencontre dans dont le dans le
palais de versailles
et effectivement je crois qu'il ya un
projet maintenant de mettre en exergue
une certaine diversification des
partenaires il faut pas compter
seulement sur les américains mais il
faut avoir des relations équilibrées
également avec les russes avec les
chinois peut être même avec avec l'âne
et avec d'autres pays émergents qu'ils
en la capacité de nous aider et
également de d'avoir un support pour la
pour la suite du projet européen
une dernière question sur cette sécurité
mondiale et les français les rues sont
d'accord pour sur la non-prolifération
nucléaire notamment
ça aussi c'est une piste pour avoir plus
de sécurité dans le monde ou pas
puisqu'on sait qu à tirer du très
exactement c'est une très très bonne
piste pour avoir plus de sécurité je
crois qu'il faut qu'il faut avoir un
très grand effort au niveau des de
désengager certainement pour se tenir ce
genre de sorts de genre de projet
l'opinion publique peut jouer vraiment à
un rôle très important là dessus
notamment notamment les médias parce que
face à tout cela on trouve qu'il ya
encore des mouvements populistes surtout
aux états unis dans certains même par un
pays européen qui continue dans ce genre
de projets qui ont un seul caractère qui
est vraiment la description du monde et
la création des gars merci beaucoup
younès belle fille là d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rtpi merci à vous de
m'avoir reçu